guten tag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz
wenn sich alle setzen dann haben wir auf
sicht vielen dank herzlich willkommen
herr professor lothar wieler den
präsident des robert koch institutes und
frau professor sandra zeck der
direktorin des institutes für
medizinische virologie am
universitätsklinikum frankfurt den
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
haben wir nicht verloren der ist im
bundestag noch und kommt sofort zu uns
wenn er dort sozusagen alles gemacht hat
was er dort tun will aber wir haben mit
blick auf die uhr und der tatsache dass
ich hier eine weitere pressekonferenz
anschließt und wir auch etwas zeit und
luft brauchen um hin und her zu gehen
und zu tauschen gedacht wir fangen jetzt
an dann der minister ist informiert weiß
das und einverstanden
und ich gebe herrn professor wieder das
wort damit vorankommen
davor will das guten tag meine damen und
herren und da und herren die korona
maßnahmen wirken und zwar nicht nur
gegen kuwait 19
wir sehen in der gesamten bevölkerung
viel weniger infektionskrankheiten als
sonst
kontakt reduktion das abstandhalten das
maske tragen die händehygiene und das
lüften verhindern eben auch dass wir uns
mit anderen erregern anstecken und das
ist gerade in diesen pandemie zeit
natürlich ein echter pluspunkt weil es
dabei hilft arztpraxen und krankenhäuser
zu entlasten weil die üblichen
infektionskrankheiten eben nicht noch
zusätzlich obendrauf kommen das
wichtigste beispiel ist hier sicher die
grippe ein ziel in diesem winter war es
ja so wenig grippefälle wie möglich zu
haben also viele grippewelle wie möglich
verhindern und das ist uns bislang sehr
gut gelungen ich sage bislang weil wir
natürlich alle nie in die zukunft
schauen können normalerweise haben wir
zu beginn eines jeden jahres immer eine
grippewelle die fällt unterschiedlich
schwer aus aber normalerweise bekommen
wir dann jede woche
mehrere tausend oder sogar mehrere
zehntausend fälle übermittelt und
tausende menschen müssen im krankenhaus
behandelt werden
im moment sehen wir aber nur 20 bis 30
grippe fälle pro woche das sind zu
wenige wie sonst nur im sommer und in
dieser saison gab es auch bislang erst
150 schwere fälle im krankenhaus die
grippewelle ist also bislang
ausgeblieben übrigens weltweit und das
ist auch ein großartiger erfolg
ähnlich sieht es auch bei vielen anderen
akuten atemwegserkrankungen aus also bei
den erkältungen anfang februar 2020 also
im letzten jahr gab es etwa 5,6
millionen akute atemwegserkrankungen in
deutschland pro woche
anfang februar diesen jahres anfang für
über 20 21 sind es gerade einmal circa
900.000 also 4,7 millionen weniger
wir sehen auch viel weniger
durchfallerkrankungen viel weniger
masernfälle für 2020 sind nur 75 masern
fälle übermittelt worden an das robert
koch institut
sonst sind es mehrere hundert muss
manchmal auch mehrere tausend heute
würde uns dazu einen artikel im
epidemiologischen bulletin
veröffentlicht den sie dann auch unsere
website www.iaa.de finden marco witt
setzt sich der trend im
infektionsgeschehen weiter fort
erfreulicherweise gehen die fallzahlen
insgesamt zurück die bundesweite 7 tages
inzidenz liegt aktuell bei 62 und sie
geht regional natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich voran
auf vielen intensivstation stabilisiert
sich die situation
sie ist aber immer noch angespannt und
leider sterben immer noch sehr viele
menschen im zusammenhang mit 19
insgesamt haben wir nun in deutschland
ans robert koch-institut 64.000 191
fälle übermittelt worden
an verstorbenen aber trotzdem sind wir
alles in allem auf einem guten weg wir
wissen auch
dass einige saß koch zwei varianten
einen boost erhalten haben dass sie
ansteckender geworden sind und dass sie
sich auch in deutschland ausbreitet
wir hatten ja letzte woche erste
ergebnisse vorgestellt wonach eine der
varianten und zwar diese variante b 11 7
die zunächst im vereinigten königreich
nachgewiesen wurde
einen anteil von etwa sechs prozent der
untersuchten proben ausgemacht hat und
in dieser woche wird diese erhebung in
den laboren noch einmal wiederholt so
dass wir dann in der nächste woche den
trend nochmals genauer anschauen und
beschreiben können aber wir gehen
natürlich davon aus dass es so wie auch
in anderen ländern in europa der fall
sein wird diese varianten zunehmen
werden deshalb auch noch meine bitte
verhindern wir doch alle wenn immer
möglich ansteckungen wir müssen die
ausbeuten der varianten zumindest
verlangsamt und wir müssen verhindern
dass neue besorgniserregende varianten
entstehen
wir alle können die virus ausbreitung
damit aktiv verhindern
das gelingt uns wenn wir alle aktiv so
viele ansteckungen wie möglich
verhindern jede infektion meine damen
und herren jede ist eine zu viel
wir müssen kein orakel befragen um zu
sehen dass die maßnahmen wirken wir
sehen in den daten dass unsere
anstrengungen die kontakt reduktion und
das einhalten der rh + l regeln also das
lüften den abstand halten hygiene
anhalten masken tragen dass diese
maßnahmen wirken
sie wirken gegen kuwait 19 und sie
wirken auch gegen viele andere
ansteckende krankheiten geben wir all
diesen krankheiten weiterhin keine
chance
danke dass es seiner frau professor jack
hat das wort ja guten morgen ich wurde
gebeten
heute einmal über antigen schnelltests
zu sprechen und selbsttests also für
jeden stehen ja kurz vor der zulassung
in deutschland und sie können auch einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten
ja um einen weg aus dem lokal zu finden
bisher gab es ja nur tests für profis
also die pcr wird normalerweise im labor
durchgeführt es gibt antigen
schnelltests für bestimmte berufsgruppen
nach einer gewissen schulung und wie
gesagt stehen selbst testen kurz vor der
zulassung
wir haben in hessen eine studie
durchgeführt mit lehrern mit über 700
lehrern vor nach den herbstferien und
haben die sich selbst testen lassen mit
einem antigen schnelltest die haben
insgesamt über 10.000 tests durchgeführt
und was wir gesehen haben ist dass das
sehr gut funktioniert hat aber die
brauchen eine gewisse anleitung das
haben wir auch gesehen hatten ein video
dazu was genau gezeigt hat wie man
diesen test durchführt und die hatten zu
uns eine 24 stunden hotline wo sie sich
uns anrufen konnten und beratung
bekommen haben oder sich natürlich
gemeldet haben wenn der test positiv
ausfiel
wie sieht so ein test aus ein bisschen
wie ein schwangerschaftstest wenn sich
zwei streifen sichtbar haben dann sind
wird der test positiv gezählt wenn ein
streifen sich bei es negativ und so eine
anleitung ist ganz wichtig dass das für
den laien verständlich ist und was auch
wichtig ist bei diesem test das haben
wir in der studie gesehen dass die eine
gewisse qualität haben müssen und vor
allen dingen die hohe spezifität das
heißt dass nicht so viele tests falsch
positiv ausfallen weil dadurch natürlich
immer eine ganze kette hinterher
also ich anschließt wie einen pcr-test
und deswegen ist es auch ganz wichtig
dass vor der zulassung der gerade läuft
die verfahren das gut getestet wird dass
diese tests eine gewisse qualität haben
und auch das versprechen was der
herstellerangaben nennt wichtig ist aber
auch und das haben wir auch in der
studie gesehen dass diese tests nicht
100 prozent sicherheit bieten also die
dürfen nicht vernachlässigen
die regeln einzuhalten das muss trotzdem
geschehen
und natürlich muss man die menschen sehr
gut aufklären dass so ein antigen
schnelltest keine adäquate medizinische
diagnose ist sondern vor allen dingen
dafür gilt dass man menschen
identifiziert die ansteckend sind und
die deswegen infektionsketten oder
sievers voller events auslösen können
und trotzdem muss man sagen ist auch ein
falsch negativer tests sehen es auch in
unserer studie gab kein beinbruch weil
vor sie gar nicht testen ist es
natürlich sinnvoll dass ein test
durchgeführt wird und man muss das
einfach als eine zusätzliche sicherheit
und möglichkeit sehen noch weiter die
pandemie einzudämmen und infektionskette
zu unterbrechen
vielen dank vielen dank frau professor
zizek herr minister sparen vielen dank
dass sie es aus dem bundestag hierher
geschafft haben und sie haben auch
gleich das wort hervor was meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren entschuldigen
sie die versprechungen aber ich denk
parlament und dann die pressekonferenz
ist die richtige reihenfolge die debatte
gegen lebhaft etwas länger als gedacht
aber scheint eine wichtige debatte ja
auch über die verlängerung der
epidemischen lage und den gesetzentwurf
der koalitionsfraktionen meine damen und
herren dieser winter ist hart
das hatten wir erwartet aber die
realität fühlt sich nach diesen vielen
wochen noch viel härter an kinder und
jugendliche wollen ihre klassenkameraden
kita freunde wiedersehen restaurant und
ladenbesitzer wollen kunden bedienen wir
alle wollen gerne wieder unseren alltag
zurück einkaufen
manche feiern gestern wäre übrigens alle
weiber gewesen in manchen regionen
dieses landes wäre gerade karneval
sie wollen zum friseur zum sport einfach
das tun was wir alle vor dieser pandemie
getan haben das geht nicht
es geht noch nicht die infektionszahlen
sinken die sinken auch ermutigen stark
wir haben eine hohe chance dass über das
wochenende die instanz bundesweit auf
unter 60 sinken kann
aber wir sind eben noch nicht stark
genug gesunken als dass wir jetzt schon
umfassend
auch die beschränkung lockern könnten
dafür ist das infektionsgeschehen noch
zu hoch die zahlen noch zu hoch und auch
die virus mutationen die uns
beschäftigen über die agra geworden ist
auch zu gefährlich wenn wir jetzt öffnen
verspielen wir den bisherigen erfolg
dieser sehr schwierigen maßnahmen auch
den erfolg den wir uns selbst der durch
verzicht durch beschränkungen durch
einschränkungen erarbeitet haben
besser jetzt noch eine weile durchhalten
als einen rückschlag zu riskieren
das ist der grundtenor des jüngsten
beschluss den die bundesregierung mit
den ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten getroffen hat es
geht vor allem darum unser
gesundheitssystem vor überlastung zu
schützen und unser gesundheitssystem das
ist nunmehr seit einem jahr stark
belastet die pflegekräfte die ärztinnen
und ärzte die apotheken die labor war
die gesundheitsämter alle bereiche des
gesundheitssystems aber unser
gesundheitssystem hat auch standgehalten
es hat sich als robust und
widerstandsfähig erwiesen und war zu
keiner zeit bisher überlastet es ist
stark belastet ist unter anspannung aber
überlastet wie wir es auch in anderen
ländern gesehen haben
das ist so bleibt ist unser gemeinsames
ziel und unser gemeinsames interesse
faktisch eröffnet der beschluss aus
dieser woche ja auch wichtige
perspektiven
es ist gut dass zug um zug schule und
kita öffnen mit klugen konzept mit
konzepten auch des schutzes vor
infektionen
das ist wichtig denn kinder und familien
und junge menschen werden durch diese
pandemie besonders belastet und wenn die
infektionszahlen regional stark sinken
stark genug sinken sind auch weitere
öffnung schritte möglich
gleichzeitig müssen wir unser land vor
dem eintrag weiterer viren schützen
deswegen haben wir in der
bundesregierung gestern beschlossenen
tschechien tirol und die slowakei zu
virusvarianten gebieten zu erklären das
bedeutet in der konsequenz ist herrscht
ein beförderungsverbot ohne ausnahmen
müssen tests vor einreise gemacht werden
und es gilt eine pflicht zur quarantäne
ich selbst bin in direkter nachbarschaft
zu den niederlanden aufgewachsen
amsterdam ist eigentlich näher als
düsseldorf und ich weiß wie wichtig
jeden tag in den grenzregionen der
austausch über die grenze ist beruflich
und in vielen auch privaten bereichen
und deswegen schmerzt diese entscheidung
besonders aber sie ist für eine gewisse
zeit unumgänglich um eine ausweitung der
gefährlichen virus varianten zu
verhindern
in tschechien zum beispiel sind diese
varianten dominierend und wohl auch
ursächlich mit für dieses dynamischen
infektionsgeschehen die inzidenz liegt
teilweise bei 5 100 über 1000 ist sogar
registriert worden eine tausende
incidents pro 100000 einwohner in den
letzten sieben tag da müssen wir
reagieren
das infektionsgeschehen diesseits der
grenze und das sehen wir jetzt schon
über viele wochen würden wir sonst nicht
in den griff bekommen ein wichtiges
werkzeug für professor die sec hat grad
darüber gesprochen in dieser pandemie
sind tests und ist noch mal sehr wichtig
zu betonen dass die art von tests die
sie auch gerade beschrieben haben für
die lehrerinnen und lehrer die
erzieherin und erzieher wir mittlerweile
durch die verordnung möglich gemacht
haben für sehr viele bereiche für alle
bereiche der sogenannten kritischen
infrastrukturen dazu gehört zum beispiel
der lebensmitteleinzelhandel drogerien
verkehrsunternehmen energieunternehmen
das heißt viele viele einrichtungen
unternehmen in deutschland können schon
heute diese schnelltests die zugelassen
sind beziehen und nach einer
entsprechenden schulung wie bei dem
gerade vorgestellten projekt auch nutzen
und ich kann nur dazu ermuntern es sind
all diesen bereichen insbesondere auch
da wo viel kontakt möglicherweise etwa
im einzelhandel ist das auch zu nutzen
ob und wann ob es eigentlich nicht die
frage eher wann auch laien test also
tests ohne schulung und auch nicht nur
für bestimmte erwerbbar sondern für alle
erwerb der dazu treten das wird sich
eben auch vor
wenn man der qualität entscheiden ja wir
haben erste anträge vorliegen aber ich
finde schon wichtig dass wir auch die
qualität prüfen
denn wenn wir zu viele falsch negative
ergebnisse haben also viele denken sie
hätten es nicht weil sie negatives
ergebnis haben aber eigentlich ist haben
und dann möglicherweise etwas unbedarfte
auch sind mit den regeln sich in
falscher sicherheit wiegen dann steckt
da drin auf ein risiko und deswegen ja
wir möchten diese tests möglich machen
die rechtliche grundlage haben wir auch
geschaffen aber wichtig ist eben dass
wir auch die qualität zu prüfen dass die
ergebnisse möglichst oft möglichst
richtig sind übrigens zu den tests bei
dem pcr tests haben wir jetzt ja eine
entwicklung dass tatsächlich wieder
kapazitäten frei haben und deswegen wir
auch die empfehlung soll bearbeiten
wollen das immer dann wenn symptome
erkennbar sind wir haben das ja wenn sie
erinnern anfang november verändert
anfang mitte november war es als die pcr
kapazitäten sehr stark belastet waren
dass nicht mehr jeder mit symptomen
getestet werden soll
die kapazitäten lassen das wieder zu so
dass wir ab nächster woche eben auch
wieder empfehlen können dass jeder mit
symptomen tatsächlich auch eine pcr
testung erhalten kann
eines noch zum impfen wenn ich kurz darf
wenn wir das thema noch natürlich auch
sehr sehr wichtig ist als dass das ja
auch zuversicht gibt wir haben 3,8
millionen impfungen stand heute in
deutschland sind über drei prozent der
bevölkerung
wir haben 15 prozent der bevölkerung mit
zweitimpfung das ist einer der höheren
anteile ich finde wichtig bei den
vergleichen zwischen den ländern nicht
nur auf die erstimpfung zu schauen
sondern auch auf die zweite impfung wenn
man sehr bewusst entschieden gerade bei
den pflegebedürftigen bei den über
80-jährigen bei den besonders
verwundbare die volle schutzwirkung
durch die zweite impfung auch zeitnah
wie empfohlen möglich zu machen die
pflegeheime die bewohnerinnen bewohner
sind zu über 80% erst geimpft über 50
prozent von ihnen haben schon die zweite
impfung erhalten und daher nicht 100
prozent das angebot annehmen dass unser
ziel eben möglichst allen
pflegeheimbewohnern und bewohnern das
angebot gemacht zu haben und um die
mitte februar
auch gut erreichbar wir haben stand
heute ausgeliefert 5,7 millionen dosen
bis ende nächster woche werden acht
millionen impfdosen in deutschland
ausgeliefert sein
stand heute 3,8 millionen impfungen die
stattgefunden haben ende nächster woche
werden acht millionen impfdosen
ausgeliefert sein das macht deutlich wie
die impfkampagne nun zug um zug woche um
woche an fahrt gewinnt auch das denke
ich es nach diesem harten schwierigen
wochen dem wichtig zu sehen wie
tatsächlich ist ja noch einige harte
wochen sind wir weil gleichzeitig eben
mit dem impfen mit dem weg raus aus
dieser pandemie schritt um schritt
besser und schneller werden und deswegen
darf ich einfach alle noch mal bitten in
diesem harten winter in dieser
schwierigen zeit
und ja eine woche ist eine lange zeit
gefühlt in diesen tagen weiterhin
aufeinander acht zu geben weiterhin
gemeinsam durch zu halten wie es ja auch
die allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
tun und unterstützen wir haben die
chance diese bisher schwierigste phase
der pandemie die wir in deutschland
erlebt haben
zug um zug schritt für schritt gemeinsam
hinter uns zu lassen
den termin ist herr minister sparen die
uns an den bildschirmen zu schauen sie
sehen hier die bundespressekonferenz das
ist ein verein von journalisten und
korrespondenten die über die
bundesregierung und die bundespolitik
und den bundestag berichten und wir
versuchen hier in eigener organisation
möglichst viele fragen zuzulassen
ich danke bei der gelegenheit auch dem
sender phoenix die uns die gebärden
dolmetscher und bereitstellen und
stichwort viel möglichst viele fragen
ich habe jetzt ungefähr schon 30 fragen
vorliegen das interesse ist sehr hoch
von außen und hier aus dem saal zusammen
ich bitte um verständnis die nicht dazu
komme ich werde auch versuchen fragen
bis hin zu straffen
damit wir möglichst viele fragen hier
viele fragen
beantwortet bekommen können und bitte
auch sich an unsere regeln zu halten
eine frage zu stellen und gegebenenfalls
eine nachfrage wenn es nötig ist henkels
der erste
zu letzteren kann ich kurz und knapp ja
sagen das ist ein ermutigendes zeichen
und zum zweiten das ist ja der anteil
des sehr wichtig zu sehen und deswegen
ist es ja sozusagen in seiner
verbreitung muss man das auch richtig
einordnen die zahl der positiv
getesteten geht zurück und der anteil
der mutation die zuerst im vereinigten
königreich entdeckt worden ist geht hoch
man kann also nicht also muss halt
aufpassen eindruck erweckt dass jetzt
auf einmal ganz deutschland mehr
infektionen die zahl der infektionen
jetzt zurück aber der anteil steigt ihr
könnt noch nicht abschließend sagen wie
stark das wird jetzt eben dieser tage
wie herr professor wieder dargestellt
hat noch mal umfassend in dieser
kalenderwoche getestet das was wir
berichtet bekommen ist dass es gestiegen
ist nach allem was die labore bis jetzt
sehen aber bis wir wirklich eine
belastbare zahl haben bitte ich noch um
weniger tage geduld ich schließe eine
frage an die von mehreren hierher
gekommen ist dass die mutationen die in
großbritannien kommt einer der
mutationen aber damit verbunden ist dass
die zahlen dort wieder sinken und die
frage ist ob sich das erklären lässt das
fragt unter anderem tim cent ivanyi von
der grund ist relativ einfach
ich nehme jetzt zunächst mal
großbritannien dort hat man als erstes
als man verstanden hat dass diese
variation bei allen altersklassen auch
deutlich stärker übertragen das hat man
dann die schulen geschlossen
wenn man dann gesehen hat dass dann die
die die schulen der anteil der schule an
dem geschehen eben größer war dann hat
man die schulen geschlossen und man hat
insgesamt die maßnahmen noch verschärft
und das ist der grund warum das die
erklärung die plausible erklärung um die
zahlen runter gehen ich denke aber noch
klarer sehen sie das in dänemark in
dänemark dort hat ja auch die
variationen in hohen anteil angenommen
und ideen haben dann auch den look down
sehr stark verstärkt und dass man sieht
an den zahlen dass diese maßnahmen
wirklich wirken also sind diese public
health maßnahmen die wir alle kennen die
sind der grund warum die zahlen runter
gehen und ich hatte das auch mehrfach
schon betont diese maßnahmen helfen ja
auch gegen alle varianten
ja das ist wirklich wichtig zu verstehen
alle maßnahmen die wir bislang kennen
diese nicht vom ökologischen oder halt
public health maßnahmen helfen auch die
übertragung der varianten zu reduzieren
noch eine frage zu den mutationen von
gernot heller vom korrespondentenbüro
herholz
ob die schätzung realistisch ist dass
die neue mutationen schon einen anteil
von rund 20 prozent der geprüften fälle
haben dass diese schätzung ist mir nicht
bekannt
[Musik]
also nochmal wir messen das erst diese
woche
was jetzt passiert ist folgendes ist
schauen natürlich jetzt viele verstärkt
auf solche varianten das heißt sie
suchen jetzt gezielt nach solchen
varianten das nennen wir verzerrungen
und dann gibt es bestimmt bestimmte
verzerrungen wo das dann eher nach oben
verzerrt wird aber ich kann dazu
wirklich etwas sagen weil wir ja mehr
oder weniger dieselbe stichprobe die wir
in der letzten woche überprüft haben in
der vorletzten die über machen wir diese
woche noch mal und dann sehen wir
nächste woche wie stark der anstieg ist
aber noch einmal ich gehe von einem
anstieg aus ganz klar ja
das entsprach also zunächst mal ist es
eine zahl die für ganz deutschland gilt
und das ist eine durchschnittszahl und
wir sehen ja jetzt auch wir haben jetzt
62 und es gibt ja auch jetzt schon
landkreise und bereiche die schon unter
50 sind und es gibt viele gehen auch
über 50 sind das heißt also diese zahl
muss man sehr stark auch immer klar in
dem biografischen kontext sehen und es
ist eben eine kennzahl aber wir haben ja
immer gesagt das ist auch eine menge von
anderen kennzahlen gibt die wir beachten
müssen und diese inzidenz ist halt die
zahl die sich am schnellsten ändert das
heißt also ist eine gute kennzahl wo man
schnell eskalieren sollte wenn man also
sieht die tendenz geht hoch dann muss
man schnell reagieren wenn man über
deeskalation spricht also darüber dass
man quasi hier und dort lockern möchte
dann ist die 10 cds zahl nicht die beste
zahl sondern gibt es andere parameter
die ein bisschen besser geeignet sind
zum beispiel die belegungszahlen der
intensivbetten weil die ja in der regel
etwa zwei wochen den krankheits
infektionsfällen hinterherläuft zwei
drei wochen
das heißt also es ist immer die eine
zahl die im vordergrund bislang steht
aber natürlich betrachten die menschen
auch andere zahlen aber sie brauchen
einen indikator ein richtwert und in dem
bereich bewegt man sich dann ich sie
wissen dass ich das unterschrieben habe
dass die publikation von frau prise man
was kann ich glaube ich auch und genau
das war die unterschrieben haben obwohl
vorkrisen mitbeteiligt waren da steht
drin ins elend von zehn habe ich auch
schon lange vor zwei wochen gesagt dass
wir eine coole zahl weil wir davon
ausgehen wenn wir zehn haben dann haben
wir 830 fälle pro tag und ich hatte
schon im frühjahr gesagt dass das eine
zahl ist wo wir wirklich gut regulieren
können und und das geschehen
kontrollieren können
und da hat sich meine einschätzung nicht
geändert ich denke dass inzwischen
wahrscheinlich sogar viele
gesundheitsämter auch was mehr noch
können weil sie im aufgeben motzt haben
an personal und auch digital
aber das ist eine zahl mit der könnten
wir super kontrollieren und das ist ja
wirklich wichtig also ich sehe das
genauso und ganz banal gesagt je
niedriger die zahl ist umso leichter ist
das infektionsgeschehen zu kontrollieren
und auch umso länger hält man das durch
das ist glaube ich das problem ist es ja
ein dynamisches geschehen und bei der 50
bleibt ist ja nicht wenn sie dann wieder
lockern haben die menschen wieder mehr
kontakte und dann werden diese zahlen
wieder ansteigen
und deshalb ist die idee dass man
möglichst niedrig diese instanz hat um
auch möglichst eine chance zu haben das
lange mit den zusatz maßnahmen wie
impfungen wie zusätzliches testen
durchzuhalten dass es nicht direkt
wieder zu einem anstieg kommt das ist
die idee dahinter super dann darf ich da
hier gleich noch eine frage hinterher
schieben von basil wegener von dpa der
fragt zur 35er incidents die länder
können laut bundespresseamt die bezugs
ebene bestimmen droht ab dieser schwelle
also an kreis also ein von kreis zu
kreis unterschiedlicher flickenteppich
bei den geschäftseröffnungen und wie
wahrscheinlich ist mit der ausbreitung
der variante überhaupt das erreichen
dieser schwelle zum siebten märz
vielleicht ja nicht was zu der stelle
und dann nochmal zu den biologischen
frage herr professor weder frau
professor z
aber erst einmal die kommen ja gerade
aus einer beratung zu einem gesetz wo
die schwellen drinsteht weil er
gelegentlich gefragt mitbekommen 35
eigentlich her im infektionsschutzgesetz
§ 28a hat der bundestag verschiedene
schwellenwerte definiert
das ist jetzt wichtig zu sehen beim
steigen der zahlen dann anzeigen und
möglich machen sollen eben und
verhältnis für verhältnismäßig dann auch
einordnen in der abwägung bestimmte
macht
sind 35 und 50 eben zwei stufen sie
stehen im gesetz sie kommen nicht von
irgendwo stehen im gesetz das finde ich
wichtig zu sehen zum zweiten ist das
konzept das angesprochen worden ist das
ist regional unterschiede gibt nach
infektionsgeschehen im grunde das
grundkonzept seit zwölf monaten für
zwölf monaten ist unser ansatz dass
grundsätzlich auch nach dem regionalen
infektionsgeschehen es unterschiedliche
vorgehensweisen geben kann und soll
was eben wichtig ist und das ist eine
lehre aus dem letzten monaten vor allem
nicht zu warten bis man sozusagen kurz
vor oder kurz hinter den jeweiligen
stellen werden ist bei wenn die 50
einmal überschritten ist das haben wir
nun wirklich oft genug erfahren dann
geht es sehr schnell sehr viel weiter
hoch also rechtzeitig vorher eingreifen
das heißt aber dann ja im umkehrschluss
in der welle runter sozusagen dann nicht
sofort bei 49 9 aufhören und sind sie ja
ständig um diese 50 rum im handel
sondern so weit runter zu kommen dass
wir tatsächlich eben auch über eine
längere phase
idealerweise über eine sehr lange phase
ist unter kontrolle behalten können auf
einem niedrigen gewohnt dieses ganze
grundkonstrukt ist angelegt im
infektionsschutzgesetz und in der
strategie seit zwölf monaten
und dann ist eben immer streiten wann
genau ist eigentlich notwendig geworden
wäre aber im herbst notwendig geworden
wieder bundeseinheitlich über die ganze
republik die gleichen maßnahmen
umzusetzen weil wir eben ein so
dynamisches geschehen insgesamt im
bundesgebiet und übrigens auch in der
europäischen union insgesamt hatten dass
wir jetzt aber zug um zug zurückkehren
dazu zu dem grundprinzip dass es eben
mit die regionalen differenzierung sich
auch widerspiegeln können in den
maßnahmen das war von anfang an ja auch
in der strategie an will ich deshalb
hier von den kollegen von draußen
zahlreiche fragen zu impfungen
die eine richtet sich an herrn minister
sparen und kommt von sascha meyer von
dpa die kanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten sprechen sich für
frühe impfungen von grundschullehrern
und erzieherinnen aus ist das richtig
und vertretbar und werden sie dem in der
impfverordnung nachkommen und hier hatte
ich noch eine weitere frage zu dazu an
frau professor zweck von gisela brühl
vom gesundheitspolitischen
informationsdienst halten sie die
immunität durch eine durchlebte cupid
erkrankung für geringer als wenn eine
kur wird impfungen durchgeführt würde
und wenn ja warum eigentlich war es noch
eine andere frage aber ich jetzt machen
wir's mal so also zuerst einmal ist ja
die bitte sozusagen nochmal anzuschauen
für die beschäftigten in den
kindertageseinrichtungen und den
grundschullehrerinnen und
grundschullehrern habe ich gerade schon
in der debatte gemerkt es geht sind
jetzt schon über alle schulen die
diskussion geht das grundschulen warum
weil eben in der diskussion zum einen
der aspekt der relevanz für die kinder
und jugendlichen gerade in dem alter von
kita und schule für ihren alltag für
ihren lebensweg sehr klar besprochen
worden diskutiert worden ist aber eben
auch dass es besonders viel schwerer ist
in dem alter bei kindern regeln und die
abstand sollte jene konzepte um und
durchzusetzen ins berner in den kitas
logischerweise und daraus ist die
diskussionen entstanden ob das in der
gewichtung und das ist ja jetzt schon so
dass die auch gesetzliche grundlage der
bundestag gegeben hat verschiedene
aspekte die zu gewichten sind neben der
frage eines schweren krankheitsverlaufs
ja auch dass der ob das in der
gewichtung eine solche rolle spielen
kann dass wir die improvisieren
verändern soll dieser bitte das zu
prüfen kommen wir natürlich nach wird
jetzt auch mit der ständigen
impfkommission darüber noch einmal das
gespräch suchen aber aber auch in der
diskussion sehr klar gemacht dass für
mich unbedingt die priorisierung gruppe
1 zuerst ein impfangebot kommen muss und
dass weiterhin auch gültigkeit hat dort
sind die besonders zu schützenden dort
jeder zweite todesfall in deutschland
ist jemand über 80 jahre
dort haben wir besonders viele schwere
und tödliche verläufe und deswegen ist
diese gruppe auf jeden fall zuerst zu
impfen da besteht auch konsens und das
ansonsten eben im zeitablauf ich dass er
im frühjahr wenn dann sähe weil
natürlich dafür dann auch ausreichende
impfdosen zur verfügung steht müssen
dass nicht andere in der priorisierung
gruppe 2 dann auf einmal weit hinten
anstehen das wird eine schwierige
debatte
wenn es dann um menschen mit
vorerkrankungen geht und erzählerinnen
und erzähler und deswegen muss dann eben
auch ausreichend impfstoff da sein
beide schauen wir uns an danke ich habe
die zweite frage jetzt gefunden die an
sie geht von der slowenischen kollegen
polona vier aus nämlich nach der
wirksamkeit von schnelltests haben sie
eigene allgemeinen daten über die
zuverlässigkeit und sind falsch positive
schnelltest teil der statistik ist die
frage die in frage kam er mit der ihm
jetzt eigene fragen bei einer also die
in frage zuerst ob eine durchgemachte
infektion besser ist als eine impfung
das kann man abschließen natürlich nicht
beurteilen aber was man sieht ist oder
was der unterschied ist wenn man eine
durchgemachte infektion hat dann bildet
man ja antikörper gegen verschiedene
teile des virus nicht nur gegen dieses
protein was in der impfung drin ist
andererseits habe sehen wir bei den
ersten daten von geimpften dass die
täter sehr hoch sind also deutlich höher
sind als die bei dem sage ich mal eine
leichte infektion durchgemacht haben wir
wissen dass die die antikörper titer die
spiegel auch relativ schnell absinken
können und deshalb kann man das sagen
ich mal vollständig gar nicht
beantworten die frage zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt es gibt ja erste studien aus
den usa
da haben die nach einer durchgemachten
infektionen bei menschen die halt dann
noch antica warten einen boost gegeben
mit dem impfstoff und da haben sie auch
nach einem buch sehr gute antikörper
antworten gesehen so dass man sagen kann
wir sehen also in wirklich in den ersten
daten nach impfungen sehr hohe
antikörpertiter höher als nach nach
leichten infektion und man muss das
jetzt einfach die nächsten wochen und
monate untersuchen inwieweit die
antikörper titer wieder abfallen wie
schnell das ist und das wichtige ist ja
auch nicht nur der antikörper spiegeln
auch die tz antworten die wir
routinemäßig gar nicht messen also unser
immunsystem ist ein bisschen komplexer
als ein antikörper und das zusammenspiel
muss man halt genau jetzt untersuchen
und zu den anti den schnelltest und der
wirksamkeit da wird ja immer eine
spezifität und eine sensitivität
angegeben und wichtig ist wenn die
angewendet werden in der großen fläche
zum beispiel bei asymptomatischen wie
zum beispiel bei den lehrern dass die
eine hohe spezifität haben das heißt
dass die vor allen dingen auch nicht
falsch falsch falsche ergebnisse liefern
dass die alle falsch positiv sind wenn
sie eine spezifität haben zum beispiel
von 99% heißt das dass einer von 100
lehrern falsch positiv ist wenn das nur
noch 95 prozent sind dann sind es schon
fünf von hundert und wenn sie mal
überlegen sich das praktisch in einer
schule überlegen und testen 100 lehrer
es gibt ja schon mit 100 lehrern wenn 1
5 an dem tag ausfallen und erstmal ne
pcr brauchen oder nur einer das macht
schon unterschiede in der fläche sagen
ich mal deswegen ist ja auch die
qualität der tests wirklich sehr wichtig
und zur sensitivität ist natürlich auch
wichtig das heißt dass auch das ergebnis
wenn es negativ ist negativ ist und wenn
es positive zusage politik wird also
dass da gibt es hersteller angaben dazu
und die werden aber natürlich immer noch
mal vom 3 auch überprüft ob die der
realität entsprechen und das ist dieser
zulassungsprozess in dem integriert
da stehe ich nicht mit drauf ich habe
mit nichts zu tun also da können sie
mich gerne fragen aber ich bin da nicht
beteiligt ja das ist ja ähnlich wie die
frage eben dass es natürlich sinnvoll
ist wenn die instanzen niedrig sind um
das infektionsgeschehen in griff zu
bekommen aber nicht wird sie bitten da
wirklich die autoren zu fragen nach den
strategien die können das denke ich geh
besser beantworten
nochmal zurück
darf ich mal schwieriger strahl ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube ich nicht zielführend
hier ist oder also weiß nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll vielleicht können sich
wenn herr jungen sie haben es doch
selbst eigentlich eingeleitet mit das
ist eine politische frage
und ich finde das ist eigentlich eine
gute arbeitsteilung zwischen
wissenschaft und politik dass
grundsätzlich der einstellte ist um
fakten geht um erkenntnisse auch
einschätzung und am ende an einer
anderen stelle nämlich da wo die
politische legitimation ist in unserem
demokratischen rechtsstaat um die
entscheidungen die daraus folgen so das
schöne ist jeder kann sich an geballter
beteiligen und das ist ja auch das was
ist so wertvoll macht diese
unterschiedlichen finde ich jedenfalls
diese unterschiedlichen zugänge und
blickwinkel
ich jedenfalls profitiere sehr mit einem
breit von einem breiten austausch und
bittet deswegen ich kann ehrlich gesagt
mit diesen zuschreibungen die sie da
machen wenn ich wenig anfangen ich hab
das in den letzten zwölf monaten auch
der begriff von fraktionen ich weiß
nicht wo sie den so wahrnehmen in der in
der öffentlichen debatte
ich habe das eigentlich als sehr
wohltuend empfunden dass wir vor allem
auch gerade in deutschland hier ein
diskurs miteinander machen
der sehr stark ja wissenschafts
getriggert ist auf wissenschaftlicher
basis ist aber am ende dann nehmen auch
weiß dass es hier nicht um absolute
wahrheiten geht oder gut oder richtig
oder falsch oder böse sondern am ende um
abwägungsentscheidung die immer auch
alle folgewirkungen zumindest versuchen
ob es immer gelingt ist eine andere
frage
alle folgewirkungen von entscheidungen
mit in den blick zu nehmen und dabei
übrigens wissen sie wenn es um das virus
geht rede ich mit virologen wenn es um
die frage von hygienevorschriften geht
redet vor allem mit hygieniker
wenn es um die wahl geht was dieses
virus in der lunge macht rede ich mit
neurologen
also ich versuche irgendwie auch mit
mehreren wissenschaftsdisziplin weil
sonst die frage ist wann die maßnahme
den kindern oder mit den menschen macht
sind auch einen psychologen zu reden
zum beispiel ich finde es ist sehr gut
eben auch in der wissenschaft breit
da auch die debatte zu suchen darin hat
die nächste frage da darf ich hier
gleich nochmal hinter her schieben die
frage von sabine von orte von der taz
der vorstand der deutschen stiftung
patientenschutz hat kritisiert dass es
keine sanktionen für diese
unberechtigten impfungen gibt von denen
immer mehr bekannt werden ob sie planen
dies zu ändern
also zuerst einmal muss ich jetzt zu
gestehen dass ich die konkrete situation
in augsburg nicht nicht überblicken
gleichwohl natürlich hier in den letzten
tagen wie eine reihe von entsprechenden
meldungen hatten und ich will das jetzt
auch mal in der sozusagen in der balance
in der abwägung beschreiben um die es da
geht es ist einerseits für mich sehr
wichtig gerade jetzt auch in dieser zeit
der absoluten knappheit des impfstoffes
dass am ende eines impft tages beim im
zentrum das feststellt wir haben noch
dosen übrig wie wir morgen nicht mehr
verwenden könnten weil sie schon re
konstituiert sind also schon der
kochsalzlösung zum beispiel in
verbindung gebracht worden sind die kann
man dann muss man jetzt nutzen das in
dieser knappheit fast alles besser ist
als wegwerfen und gleichzeitig ist aber
auch wichtig ist auch für diese
situation nur zu sagen regeln zu haben
und ich weiß von vielen impfzentren und
auch ländern die sich damit diese jetzt
auch für sich sozusagen sortiert haben
dann im zweifel medizinisches personal
das in der klinik nebenan schnell
sozusagen erreichbar ist
sicherheitskräfte feuerwehrleute
diejenigen die vielfach auch in der
priorisierung gruppe 1 oder 2 dann
selbst sind dann geimpft werden das
macht ja auch unbedingt sinn wenn es um
die frage geht darüber hinaus zu gehen
es ist eigentlich eine frage von ich
sage mal auch politischer klugheit dass
wenn ich in politischer verantwortung
bin und es eine entsprechende verordnung
gibt es im zweifel nicht besonders gutes
beispiel ist von solidarität dann dran
zu sein und deswegen werde ich mit den
ländern noch mal darüber sprechen ob wir
sozusagen noch ein stück verbindlich
aber eigentlich denke ich mir manchmal
muss er nicht vielleicht muss man doch
aber jeden lebensbereich durch
verrechtlichen oder ob man nicht schafft
pro im zentrum da einfach auch in
rückkopplung auf basis der in verordnung
dieses vorgehen das sich gerade
beschrieben hat für sich zu definieren
und festzulegen wenn abends was über ist
fragen wir bei der klinik nach oder
haben schon mit der klinik vorher
geklärt werden dran wäre oder bei den
feuerwehrleuten und polizisten im
einsatz
die eben auch schnell verfügbar sein
müssen und andersrum das thema der
sanktionen
das infektionsschutzgesetz an sich zum
beispiel kennt ja natürlich auch
sanktionen bei der bußgeld bewährung
angefangen
auch dort werden wir jetzt prüfen mit
dem bundestag im rahmen des
gesetzgebungsverfahren dass er heute
begonnen damit der debatte gerade ob
sanktionen in dem bereich sinn machen
können
man denkt ja manchmal man könnte ohne
aber an die diskussion ist angesichts
der vorfälle der letzten zwei drei vier
wochen die bekannt geworden sind
natürlich schon eine nachvollziehbar
jetzt geht es den kollegen hier oben
weiter ich bitte schon mal um
entschuldung ich habe noch zehn
wortmeldungen hier allein aus dem saal
die ich hier mit denen wir nicht
durchkommen werden
andere feiern
also die diskussion an sich ist
natürlich eine die ich verstehe vor
allem in der zeit jetzt die eben für
viele gerade auch für viele
einzelhändler aber auch für viele andere
die unternehmerisch tätig sind ja ein
existenzieller ist eine sehr sehr harte
zeit ist die entscheidung vor allem ja
auch mit blick auf friseure ist ja so
habe ich die debatte auch empfunden was
überhaupt mittwoch zwischen bund und
ländern dem mit auch in den blick nimmt
fragen von von tatsächlich körperpflege
gerade auch bei älteren boeing die frage
ist die unterstützung brauchen dafür die
frage dass das äußere für viele
natürlich auch was damit zu tun hat wie
sie sich selbst fühlen und empfinden
dass diese aspekte dabei mit eine rolle
gespielt haben bei dieser entscheidung
und deswegen übrigens andere körper es
war ja eigentlich mal der oberbegriff
körpernahe dienstleistung andere
bereiche körpernah dienstleistung die im
zweifel nicht so sehr mit dem verbunden
sind was ich gerade beschrieben haben
nicht geöffnet worden sind zum ersten
zum ersten märz aber klar das ist wissen
sie das ist ja genau die debatte und die
herausfordernde schwierigkeit vor der
wir stehen mehr fast beim öffnen als
beim beschränken
das in einer abfolge zu machen die
idealerweise so nachvollziehbar und gut
erklärbar wie möglich ist den
unterschiedlichen aspekten rechnung
trägt aber irgendwie auch akzeptanz
behält und das manchmal ist das öffnen
fast schwieriger als die entscheidungen
zu treffen zu beschränkungen zu kommen
wenn sie es wirklich so machen wollen
das ist als möglichst fair empfunden
wird also ich verstehe dass es
ich verstehe die debatte bitte aber eben
diesen aspekt den ich gerade genannt
habe
noch mal besonders zu sehen dass das
jetzt nach so vielen wochen für viele
eben tatsächlich auch eine frage von
körperpflege ja durchaus auch in der
eigenen verständnis von würde im bild
nach außen ist da darf ich noch eine
frage von delphine von la crosse
frankreich anschließend die nämlich nach
der epidemiologischen begründung fragt
warum kinder zwischen elf und 16 jahren
noch nicht in die schule gehen dürfen
also das ist die abwägung die ja eben
dann getroffen werden muss von in dem
fall neben politikern also es ist klar
dass sich kinder in schulen anstecken
können das wissen wir und darum gibt es
ja seit langem nach vielen monat gibt es
empfehlungen
wenn die schulen geöffnet werden dass
sie dann unter bestimmten schutzkonzepte
geöffnet werden mit den schutz konzepten
können wir die gefahr der infektionen
reduzieren dass die abwägung und die ist
ja wichtig das wissen wir alle
die gründe warum schulen wichtig sind
warum die schuleröffnung sich dies für
die kinder für das bildungsniveau der
kinder für den sozial kontakt der kinder
das ist eine abwägung ja aber ich kann
nur noch mal sagen wir müssen eben dann
schulen mit schulkonzept mit guten
konzepten öffnen dann kann man die
infektionsgefahr reduzieren
die empfehlung gibt es lange es gibt ja
jetzt übrigens sensationell schnell seit
montag sogar leitlinien dafür die mit
der arbeitsgruppe unter der leitung von
frau rehfuß aus münchen etabliert wurden
und publiziert wurden die waren wir in
der faz glaube ich auch am montag
es gibt also leitlinien wie man das
machen kann und das sollte man dann auch
tun und sie hat noch eine nachfrage die
eltern das mit dem alter denken der
grund ist ganz einfach was wir auch
wissen ist dass die die das
ansteckungsrisiko die ansteckung dynamik
bei älteren ein größeres ist als bei
jüngeren
wissen wir dass das zeigen alle daten
die wir bislang haben wir wissen die
gründe nicht so ganz genau aber wir
sehen dass eine epidemiologische studien
und den zweiten grund hatte minister
spanne eben auch schon genannt
bei den kleineren ist es halt insgesamt
auch ein bisschen schwieriger die die
konzepte mit denen durchzuführen und die
größeren können eben besser auf sich
aufpassen und können auch natürlich
besser homeschooling machen und können
besser auch geschult wird aus sagt der
schulen dass das gelingt den natürlich
besser jetzt habe ich erst letzte für
heute noch frisch zuerst einmal ist das
gesundheitsportal als information für
die bürgerinnen und bürger ja nicht
betroffen von dem von dem urteil das ist
ein informationsangebot das wir übrigens
auf basis des koalitionsvertrages und
nach einer gesundheitspolitischen
diskussion die wahl bestimmt an die zehn
jahre lang geht
das ist ein solches gesundheitsportal
braucht auch um im online und schnell
verfügbar
auch von den institutionen des
gesundheitswesens dem weg weg vom
institut für qualität im
gesundheitswesen von den
fachgesellschaften hergeleitete
fachinformationen leicht zugänglich zu
machen und in der pandemie hat sich aus
unserer sicht noch mal eine besondere
notwendigkeit ergeben gerade mit blick
auf corinna koop 19
tatsächlich all den informationen und
teilweise falsch und fehlinformationen
die auch mit unterschiedlichen
interessen online gestellt werden eben
noch mal auch dieses informationsportal
daneben zu stellen
und natürlich haben wir uns darüber
gefreut dass es dann auch möglichst
leicht zu finden war
das steht außer zweifel das wird jetzt
nicht mehr so leicht zu finden sein aber
ich halte es weiterhin für wichtig diese
informationen zu geben übrigens auch
unsere bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung der bund
geld aufklärend und sachlich
informationen über krankheit über
prävention von erkrankung wahrscheinlich
länger zur verfügung als ich auf der
welt bin eher wenig über die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung über nachdenke und ihren
auftrag den sie hat und das ministerium
auch und diesem auftrag jetzt auch in
digitalen zeiten gerecht zu werden indem
man nicht nur flyer druckt und nicht nur
für einzelne erkrankungen vielleicht
angebote hat sondern einmal gebündelt
als informationsportal des bundes das
halten wir weiterhin für richtig und das
ist so ist ja auch das urteil weiterhin
auch möglich also ich gehe jetzt noch
mal in meinem ein cut wäre jetzt hier
wegen des hygiene konzept ist dass wir
hier genug platz haben dass die können
doch es würde nach machen
okay gut das ist wunderbar und es hat
mir signalisiert dass das geht ja nun
aber arbeit hier ist noch sehr viel
bedarf bei ihnen
sie haben die nächste frage bitte also
zum einen geht es ja darum dass wir die
empfehlen wenn sie zwei november wieder
als wir die empfehlung geändert haben
weil wir im november gesehen haben
das ist sehr sehr viele nachfrage nach
testen gab und am ende der überhang also
da wo es dann zwei drei tage dauerte das
man auf ein testergebnis wartet so groß
geworden ist dass das nicht mehr nicht
mehr gut war schlicht und ergreifend und
wir deswegen gesagt wir müssen die zahl
der tests jetzt erstmal reduzieren indem
wir sagen nicht jeder mit symptomen muss
per se getestet werden entscheidend ist
das erstmal jeder mit symptomen in
quarantäne geht so jetzt sehen wir erst
gerade dargestellt dass die grippe sich
gottseidank durch die maßnahmen aber
auch durch die umfangreiche
grippeimpfung wenn sich wahrscheinlich
so viele deutsche grippe geimpft haben
wie noch nie zuvor nicht richtig fuß
fassen kann im grunde gar nicht dass wir
auch ansonsten die infektionszahlen bei
kubi 19 entsprechend gesunken sind wir
insgesamt was haben wächst erkrankungen
angeht der größenordnung haben wo wir
und gleichzeitig freie kapazitäten
wieder haben wo wir eben diese
empfehlung im grunde wieder auf das
ändern können was vor dieser veränderung
im november gegolten hat dass nämlich da
wo symptome sind daneben der arzt auch
einen pcr-test um vornehmen können soll
und das wird dann in den fluss schemata
wie das fachlich heißt also in der in
der frage der hinweise für die ärzte
dann auch entsprechend abgebildet
abgebildet werden wichtig ist übrigens
für alle die auch zu schauen natürlich
idealerweise den arzt vorher anrufen
wenn man symptome hatten termin
vereinbaren damit dann das
infektionsrisiko in der praxis durch die
zeitabläufe die dann organisiert werden
möglichst reduziert ist sodass es
möglich jetzt eben mit dem pcr-test
kapazitäten die andere frage bezog sich
jetzt auf die neuen tests
erst einmal geht es jetzt um die frage
wie welche zugelassen werden und dann
werden wir mit den ländern darüber reden
wie wir es ja auch bei den antigenen
schnell testen nachschulung sozusagen
gemacht haben ob und wie wir sie in die
strategie aufnehmen ist es am ende ja
auch eine frage
ich habe auch noch ehrlicher weise keine
abschließende vorstellen davon zu
welchem preis die am ende verfügbar sein
werden im einzelhandel